This course has, mainly, 3 goals.
After having taken this course, you will be able to recognize
what makes a problem challenging for a computer to solve.
You will also have an understanding of why these problems are challenging.
And through that understanding, I will show you a number of techniques
that you can use to navigate around computational complexity.
So this course will not only enable you to recognize and understand tough problems
but also give you many tools and techniques that you can use
to actually solve them in practice.
And this is something that, in my experience, is not taught very often.
So some people will be able to recognize that a problem is challenging;
fewer people will understand what makes these problems challenging.
But when it comes down to knowing the techniques that you can use
to solve these challenging problems, despite their computational complexity,
then my experience is that knowing these techniques can really make you stand out.
During this course we will come across many algorithms
especially when we study complexity theory, but this is not a course about algorithms in general.
Rather, they will be a means to an end, to understand what makes problems hard,
and, of course, also to navigate around computational complexity.
So for taking this course you should have a basic understanding of algorithms,
although we'll also cover the basics to make sure that you all start out on the same level.